hola a todos hoy vamos a aprender cómo
tendríamos que guiarnos sus estudiantes
para que empiecen a usar khan academy
tenemos que primero pedirles que se
registren como hicimos nosotros como
maestros pero ellos con una cuenta de
estudiantes para eso tienen que hacer
clic en la parte superior derecha donde
dice regístrate
aquí ellos pondrán como estudiante y
pondrán su fecha de nacimiento
si son menores de 13 años les va a pedir
la plataforma que los padres de una
aprobación desde sus correos para que
puedan usar canales si son mayores de 13
años no va haber ningún problema
entonces pone en su año la fecha y hacen
clic en regístrate con tu correo
electrónico
de igual forma como hicimos con los
maestros ellos tienen que poner el
correo electrónico que usen normalmente
ya sea de la escuela de la universidad o
su correo personal como por ejemplo
puedo poner este correo
puede ser cualquier tipo de servidor
gmail hotmail que sea
vamos a poner aquí el nombre
y vamos a poner una contraseña que sea
de más de 8 caracteres y por lo menos
con una letra y número
ahí le hacemos clic a regístrate
e inmediatamente lo que le aparece al
estudiante es primero un cuadro donde le
preguntan en qué grado está imaginemos
que está estudiante maría está en guarda
secundaria
la aquí a continuar y luego le pregunta
qué cursos quiere aprender en caracas
imaginemos que ella quiere aprender
macroeconomía y geometría básica puede
continuar con los dos cursos e
inmediatamente la plataforma ya les
sugiere temas con los cuales comenzaron
el estudiante lo que ve en esta primera
en esta primera pantalla es bueno en su
nombre puede cambiar su nombre de
usuario
como una foto aquí sirven las partes
derecha las medallas que van ganando
porque cada cadena tiene un sistema en
el que estudiante va ganando puntos y
medallas conforme va aprendiendo
y aquí en la parte inferior puede ir
inclusive viendo videos o cálidos por la
misma plataforma
para que el estudiante comience a usar
khan academy como
participante de una de nuestras clases
lo que tiene que hacer es ir a la
pestaña donde dice tutores
y aquí tiene que agregar el código de la
clase que el maestro haya creado para
eso previamente tiene que haber creado
una clase nosotros ya teníamos una clase
creada
la que
ponemos el código
no importa si el código está en
mayúscula o minúscula de todas formas se
puede hundir a la clase ya que le sale
el estudiante que ha ingresado con éxito
la clase si el estudiante en este
momento va
nuevamente a su página de inicio
va a ver que todavía no le aparece
ninguna mención de las tareas que tiene
porque el profesor previamente tiene que
aceptarla en la clase
si ven en la esquina superior derecha se
abre una notificación
en la que dice que ya su tutor en este
caso que se llama contacto perú
ha ingresado dentro de su clase
pero falta que el profesor la acepte
en este caso vamos a salir de la cuenta
de estudiante
y vamos a volver a entrar como maestros
para poder aceptar a esta nueva
estudiante
aquí en mi página de maestro en la que
he vuelto entre la clase que cree en
matemáticas quinto a
y como verán me parece que ya tengo un
nuevo estudiante en la clase que es
maría que acaba de agregarse a mi clase
y le diré actualizar
e inmediatamente maría ya le va a
parecer que está en la clase y que tiene
tareas que son las que ya han podido
dejar antes
así es la forma como los estudios